dire cet accord il faut la preuve qu'il
est pas majoritaire puisque il y a
encore des salariés qui sont
majoritairement en grève faux sur 14000
salariés faut archi faux
[Musique]
2000 et moins peut-être moins de 300
donc faut en plus il dit puisque ces
accords là faudrait les soumettre à
référendum de l'entreprise mais là c'est
stérile dans le pied quand on est une
organisation syndicale à quoi sert
aujourd'hui la négociation collective et
la négociation sociale dans une
entreprise il faut soumettre l'accord
des organisations qui je le rappelle des
élections ont eu lieu je crois que
c'était en mars avril avec c'est vrai
une progression de la CFDT mais donc un
accord qui est majoritaire signé par
deux organisations syndicales qui
apportent des avancées concrètes parce
qu'au final c'est pas tellement la
polémique qui m'intéresse moi c'est ce
que ça apporte aux travailleurs et aux
travailleuses de chez Total il y a une
augmentation salariale qui est
conséquente ça veut pas dire que c'est
la fin de l'histoire on sait pas ce qui
se pas l'an prochain dans les mois à
venir il y a même une clause de revoyure
prévue en janvier si les choses devaient
s'emballer au niveau de l'inflation mais
moi vous savez ce qui m'importe c'est
pas que les syndicalistes ils fassent de
l'agitation ce qui m'importe c'est
qu'ils obtiennent des salades des
avancées pour ceux pour qui ils
travaillent normalement ils
s'investissent c'est à dire les
travailleurs et travailleuses vous
comprenez que quand on vous entend parce
que c'est fort ce que vous dites on a il
y a 14000 salariés qui vont
effectivement bénéficier d'un accord que
les syndicats majoritaires ont signés il
y en a moins de 300 qui bloque tout il y
a des gens qui font la queue pendant
deux heures et demie pour remplir
ce disent mais alors c'est un dévoiement
c'est un dévoiement quand même je crois
je crois que je crois que ça fait pas du
bien ou syndicalise vous savez je crois
que le syndicalisme c'est ça se mesure
aux avancées que ça obtient pour les
salariés qu'il représente et pas au
niveau d'emmerdement qu'il crée pour les
Français
mais
sur cette affaire là vous pouvez
constater classer FDT elle est plutôt
dans la première catégorie c'est-à-dire
les avancées qu'elle est aucun pour les
salariés concernant les emmerdements
pour les Français malheureusement c'est
pas de mon ressort